we need to speak up the time is now
right it is now we don't want to end up
where Europe is now but we will end up
there if we don't do anything about it
uh Elon Musk who again has been leading
the charge on this in that he has opened
up X so that we are able to see more and
more of these videos uh he had a a good
tweet on what's going on in Denver we
just showed you that video from Denver
and he retweeted it he wrote If Denver
is having trouble with 40,000 illegals
how will they handle the next
400,000 the legal influx is growing
exponentially and just exceeded babies
born in America last month did you catch
that last part I think we might have
reference the chart was going around
about a month ago where there are now
more illegals coming into the country
than Americans having babies L that out
do some basic math I know math is racist
but you do that over time do you think
we might end up a little bit more like
Somalia do you want to live in Somalia
no neither do I so we have to wake up
Americans of all political stripes and
that gets us back to where we started at
the top that you now have a lefty like
Russell bran sitting down with a righty
like Tucker Carlson and going there's a
whole bunch of here our our
prescriptions for the and our policies
maybe disagree we may feel different
things on abortion or this or that but
but we are acknowledging what the actual
problem
is